I mean are you just exhausted you've had
such a busy month you were just in
Europe I was I was in France yesterday
oh my God God I was in France yesterday
oh my God now you're at the amas how
does it feel it feels absolutely amazing
this is obviously such a dream come true
and I'm just so excited to be here like
what is happening and then to be
nominated for best new artists of the
year with amazing company are you
pinching yourself I am pitching myself
even to be on that Zoom call with all of
those incredible artists and find out we
all got nominated like it's just such an
honor to be a part of like I I genuinely
can't believe it do you have a speech
prepared just in case no you don't no I
know I'm gonna lose it's a-okay it is
okay you don't know that though oh I
know I'm completely comfortable in it
that's that's totally fine like I'm
excited to be here I get to wear a dress
you know I get to do the thing you know
but I'm gonna lose and it'll be great um
now do you have a Grammy's dress picked
out because you were nominated I didn't
pick out a trip you have time I have
time thank God I had no clue I had no
clue I had no no idea again I can't wait
to lose it's such a beautiful year of
losing what and such a wonderful year of
getting nominated it's just so exciting
before a debut like this to be nominated
in a huge category like song of the year
for your songwriting that must feel
extra special it it feels incredible and
something that honestly makes me so
happy I'm literally getting emotional
over this I've been writing songs to my
best friend since I was 12 and she was
15 and we started spreading songs in my
bedroom and to get to say they were
Grammy nominated songwriters is so
exciting to get a shirt together we
wrote the song when I was 16 and she was
19 and the fact that we could get Grammy
nominated off of it it's absolutely
ridiculous and it just makes
me so I'm so happy for you all I can say
to that is whoever that's whoever that
boy that song is about ha look what you
did you create a grammy-nominated artist
all right wait real quick so when we
talk to you at the EMAs uh you were
obviously about to go on tour with
Taylor you're excited to see her did you
guys get to meet up and hang out at all
we did I got to congratulate her on
winning all of those incredible Awards I
believe she won four MTV email Awards
which is absolutely incredible she's
about to win so many awards tonight
which I'm so excited to see and yeah I
just got to I never actually got to in
person personally thank her for putting
me on the tour and the last thing she
said to me the first time we met was
I'll see you again and then the first
thing she said to me was see I told you
I'd see you again and I was like I love
it what is happening your reaction to
the fans who couldn't get tickets oh I
love you and uh thank you for possibly
being a fan of me but also American
Music Awards are pretty awesome
foreign